TO FINALLY SEE HER AGAIN.
[sighs]
LILLY.
- [giggling]
- OH!
WOW.
WHAT ARE THOSE?
- HI, BILLY.
FUN AND NEW.
YOU WANT TO COME OUT
AND PLAY WITH US?
- BOOBS.
BOOBS.
BOOBS!
- I'M BACK!
- OH, GOD.
IF WALLS COULD HAVE BABIES,
THIS WOULD BE CHINA.
DUDE, WHAT'S YOUR PROBLEM?
- LILLY'S NEW BOOBS!
- WHAT WERE THEY?
WERE THEY, LIKE, "BEE STINGS"
OR WERE THEY, LIKE,
FULL-ON WATERMELONS?
- I WANT TO SEE HER BOOBS.
NO, I WANT TO SEE ALL BOOBS.
NO, I WISH I COULD SEE
ALL BOOBS ALL THE TIME!
- JIZZAM!
[ethereal music]
- WE'RE PERKY.
- WE'RE BOUNCY.
- WE'RE SUSPICIOUSLY
SYMMETRICAL.
- THIS IS THE BEST DAY
OF MY LIFE!
NOTHING CAN RUIN THIS!
- BILLY, YOU FORGOT YOUR LUNCH.
- NO!
- [laughing wickedly]
BILLY, REMEMBER
WHEN WE USED TO FEED YOU?
[slurping]
DID I TELL YOU
I GOT NIP RINGS?
- [moaning]
- [chuckling]
I KNOW.
HOW 'BOUT THAT?
- [yelling]
- DON'T FORGET
TO DRINK YOUR MILK.
- WHEN BOOBS HAVE LOST
THEIR MAGIC,
HOW IS LIFE WORTH LIVING?
- OH, IT ISN'T.
THAT'S WHY I'D LIKE
TO INTRODUCE YOU
TO INTERNET PORN...
[shimmering tone]
WHERE THE COMBINATIONS
OF BODY PARTS AND HOLES
AND PENISES ARE AS LIMITLESS
AS YOUR IMAGINATION.
- [grunting]
[moaning]
[groans]
I CAN'T FEEL ANYTHING
ANYMORE.
- BUT AWESOME BOOBS, RIGHT?
- I DON'T WANT
TO LIVE THIS WAY.
I WISH I WEREN'T
SO DESENSITIZED.
- JIZZAM.
- [sobbing]
- LILLY?
WHAT'S WRONG?
- ALL THE BOYS WON'T STOP
STARING AT MY BOOBS.
- BUT YOU'RE MORE
THAN JUST YOUR LOOKS.
YOU'RE SMART AND COOL AND--
- AND THE A.C.'S
ON FULL BLAST.
- BOOBS!